bonjour à tous alors on se retrouve
toujours avec saint-amand et on va
regarder aujourd'hui une partie il a
inhalé noir contre il y à saint-henri
boncourt lui je le connaissais pas mais
c'était un des bons joueurs français
dans ces années là on va dire début
début des années 1800 quoi donc cette
partie était jouée en 1837 au café de la
régence comme bien souvent donc monsieur
boncourt à l'eiblen saint-amand les
noirs et c'est parti alors c'est une 4 5
il a joué fous ces 4 au second qui avec
6 des trois donc début du fou mais très
vite après qu'alex trois qualités 6 on
voit que sar transpose dans une
italienne très classique
on voit maintenant fait même beaucoup de
parties par actuellement je vais dans
cette annonce est libre donc les bleus
ont fait ces trois très bien aussi très
bien faire petit rock ici mais c'est
royer pas de souci et avec les noirs il
a joué sous les 6 alors c'est peut-être
un poil tour mais illarine social à dire
on est plus habitué à redire avoir soit
petit rock ici soit le coût 10 6 dans
cette position mais faux mais si ce pas
grand chose à critiquer les bons fait
petit rac les noirs aussi et les blancs
fut g5
alors pourquoi pas cette louve cavaliers
évidemment une autre option serait se
développer tranquillement avec kelly
bélie 2 et sur 10 6 par exemple reculé
le four est ce que faire attention des
clés noires font des six ils peuvent
venir faire cavalier à 5 éventuellement
pour s'en prendre nous faut donc on aime
bien enlevé et voilà une fuite jusqu'à
logique cependant qui a lieu cette côte
et noir on sait que ça c'est le genre de
manoeuvre très typique le cahier du bon
côté sur une bonne case et puis aussi
parfois permet de faire ses six t5 et
puis les bras que je prends le cas ici 4
bon ça je vous dis et plein de partis
même récente là dessus mais fou g5 pas
mal donc sa salle avantages du cloud et
m6 ça va empêcher aussi autour d'eux
au d5 est le seul truc en fait à savoir
c'est que c'est bien de le fou g5
une fois que les noirs et petit rock
parce que quelques bords les invite à
faire un truc comme h6 g5 pour enlever
le clouage avancer les pions et si l'on
va faire petit rock ça peut leur donner
de l'adac là comme ça sera quand même
plus difficile pour un lieu des 6 il a
joué de b4 d'autres où serait possible
mais b49 fois très bien faut aussi ce
qu'avait les béziers 2 donc finalement
partie très classique et ai je donc
comme lille en 1837 mais on la verrait
nos jours il y aura rien de choquant
pour l'instant h 6 x h 4 watts et a été
joué donc pourquoi pas à quatre menaces
dont un an ferme et le faut et il fait à
six alors là il ya un petit coup droit
h1 pas forcément indispensable mais ma
foi c'est pas absurde
une des idées peut être que je pourrais
comprendre là dessus c'est que si un
jour les noirs rouges et 5 rouges et
trois cavaliers h cinq équipes rennes
angers 3 entreprend de pions f
ce qui serait pas mal pour les pour les
blancs ou en mai
et finalement une autre option ici je
pense ça serait pas te prendre ans le 6
sur pied on préfère fouquereuil f6 parce
que les sans terre il faut après j'ai
cinq bougies train dame prend est par
exemple un coup comme cai c4 sur x 7
peut-être b5 avec pourquoi pas dans
certains cas l'intention de faire même
b6 ensuite pour taper sur des 6 ou
créent des faiblesses en tout cas
prendre un avantage de développement
elle dame fin développement des spas
salle adam peut-être jouer des quatre un
jour voilà salaire un peu mieux pour les
blancs mais faut toujours bien évident
faire un peu attention elle roi parce
que les noirs y à deux fois 7 et la
polonaise donc être assez prophylactique
dans ce genre de position mais ok il à
faire au rachat est donc les clés noires
il va tenter un plan assez offensif il
nous fêtons j'évite donc il veut il veut
pousser les pions comme c'est le g5 coup
j'ai 3 h 5
donc c'est vrai ça offensif ils menacent
h4 pour enfermer le fou donc jeu très
ambitieux de la part des noirs etc les
mêmes effets h3 pour cacher le fou juste
quand même ici je dois dire que je
pensais à clément il ya un moyen pour
davantage en échangeant des ans et
autres fers h3 jouer h4 ça ne sent quand
même bien mieux l'idée en fait c'est que
si j'ai quatre on a qualifié 5 et en cas
de prise et pourra reprendre du fourrage
4 et c'est même le roi noir pourrait
commencer être dans les courants d'air
donc h4 dans le monde meilleure réplique
que le simple h3 mais ok c'est pas
dramatique bertrand h4 le vous 120
cavaliers h5
donc on voit qu'avec les noirs ils
commencent à se rapprocher mais avec les
blancs il fait un truc très bien c'est
qu'ils jouent des quatre et ça c'est un
grand principaux échecs quand on est
attaqué à l'ale non il faut réagir au
centre donc bien joué bien jouer et puis
en plus on voit qu'ils créent
éventuellement le vis-à-vis avec laurent
bon avec les north de son île se désunit
pas et l'on voit prises ici prise ici et
des prend pour le sang en fait c'est
très bien ce qui fait parce que ils
attaquent ce pion trois fois
et tête noire va peut-être arriver mais
pour l'instant rien de très concret et
là il joue un truc intéressant
bon en fait d'où 2 mai moyen malin de
défense et qui jettera il donne la pièce
donc tu comprends puis on prend et
justes en fait avec le fou qui couple
ici et là colonna il veut rentrer dans
des réseaux de matrouk entre l'europe où
avec les bleus alors bien défendre et
aurait déjoué tour à d un sas est
toujours plutôt bien court avec un temps
d'1 me bouge b5 chasse aux cavaliers ils
espèrent un vote culture il va s'en
aller de prendre ici mais là je pense
qu'il est tout calculer et continue par
le pourtour h4 entourage quatre c'est
quoi l'idée c'est que si par exemple ou
prend cette pièce ici il ya tout
reproche de cavaliers pros forcée d'un
mach 4 et vous faire deux trois échecs
mais on va se prendre un bain rech
d'obuda prennent donc donc menace très
dangereuse des blancs des noirs
après tours h4 est là ok fallait fallait
trouver la meilleure défense je pense je
pense que le truc pm trouvable c'était
de faire tourner trois alors c'est quoi
l'idée en fait c'est une structure soit
trop déranger pour venir sans promotion
du droit
l'idée en fait c'est que le réseau de
matches comme ça mais les noms peuvent
le mettre en place mais on va sacrifier
la tour sur ce point me prend et comme
il y avait ceux qui traînaient à la fin
on peut le prendre et on va rester
qu'une pièce de plus ils attaquent noir
et quand même vraiment réduite ont bâché
c'est la dame a fondé une pièce de plus
on peut prendre le fou on va passer
remater juste avec une dame tout seul et
ça ferait même gagnant donc du coup pour
les blancs mais il fallait voir tout ça
il a raté et il a pris en v6 bon salaire
quand même assez logique de prendre un
v6 parce qu'on enlève ce fou qui est un
carton jaune mais qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est qu'il fait orange ii et donc
commande précédente cavalli prendre va
pas dire encore les histoires avec deux
matches 4 dont on apprend à jouer fait
enrager 1 et dames ces cinq échecs
du coup seul coup tout en f2 maintenant
il reprendre des six du coup les
n'auront à peu près restaurer le liquide
du matériel et les blancs gobain garde
mais il ya quand même des pièces qui
arrivent
le roi blanc donc ici il a fait il l'a
fait cai proche de 2 à l'autre coup à
regarder éventuellement cette épure
processus mais le problème pour les
blancs pas si ça c'est la tour noire à
les sablons s'en aller par exemple
courage 5 et on gardait le clouage
regardait le clouage sur la tour donc on
va regagner au coup suivant où quand on
veut et on aura une qualité plus donc il
a plutôt bien joué dans la partie en
prenant h2 hockey mineur en prie prie et
le tour et fit don qui rajoute une
charge sur f2 hilare des cavaliers pour
contrer
donc à l'heure actuelle les blancs
histoire plus mais on voit bien que ça
pas du réel en prise mais ils se
pressent pas pour l'apprendre ça c'est
aussi un truc assez important général
quand vous clouer une pièce bons plans
serrés sur la dame sait jamais mais
quand c'est le roi derrière toute façon
à ne pas partir donc c'est touré à nous
et on peut l'apprendre plus tard
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui fait effet kerry
à 5
donc il soustrait le cahier attaque et
il concernerait un peu sur les cases tam
eux deux qui allie ces quatre là bon
c'est un peu coupé d'épée dans l'eau
il a fait cheikh rage et six maps et est
reparti tour f4 la petite faute quand
même il fait autour des 3 le truc c'est
qu'on comprend ce que l'on veut faire ce
qu'ils veulent prendre deux fois en deux
par un pion prend d'apprendre à me
prendre à prendre excursion en l'air à
la fin du coup ce qui semblerait logique
c'est soit défendre icade soit pas un
jeu tout comme tours des f1 passif
certes mais dur pour les noirs de faire
vraiment beaucoup de deux nouvelles
menaces et souhaite toujours pulsions km
qui va se tenir pour les blancs il a
fait tourner trois équipes encore
catastrophique mais dans l'histoire ça
lâche ses pions mais il fait tour 17
et il va trouver le contre eux les noirs
il a joué thouars f4 dont ils menacent
éventuellement 4
et ce qui le menace vraiment c'est en
fait sur quatre les blancs ou faire
rager 3 et attaquer la tour donc il se
dit ok je tacle à tour il s'en va je
voudrais à mon cavalier j'ai pas de
souci je vais prendre 17 ont cédé son
raisonnement il a quand même sauvegarde
par les différents chez 3 et il a pris
de la même surprise il a eu abandon
pourquoi parce que si on prend la tour
emma le pion fils adam f1 d'abu prochain
et c'est terminé
du coup les rares fatidique elle se
trouve ici après tout avec 4 il fallait
surtout pas les prendre 17 mai ceux des
clous avec le roi alors le goût qui est
logique 0e deux mois à voir qu'on fait
romain meyer pourquoi passer par le cnf
autour g4 pour s'en prendre à ses pions
pas de l'option n'est pas vraiment
prises qu'on peut prendre mais sur ce
tour prend f2 et à la fourchette 1 h 4
ans et c'est ça l'intérêt de ne pas voir
2003 ici passent prendre les chèques
donc surtout prouvé cet oncle et noir
ferait un truc comme on rêve 5 sa
solution pas claire mais objectivement à
peu près égale équilibré mais bon mais
blanc à terre ils ont fait on prend 17
et ils se sont pris ce joli truc et donc
il va bande ont donc voilà victoire de
saint-amand c'était une partie assez
dynamique assez un email la tactique
j'espère que ça vous a plu
allez à bientôt ciao ciao